hi guys I'm back playing friend Bo again
for you I gotta risk toc last time but
you guys have been amazing and they have
helped me out so let's see if we can
progress in this awesome game last time
um I found what were they I Kevin but
they were some little little small
animals and I was trying to get what was
it run again berries it's been so long
anyway what is that that I missed
something in the miscellaneous pile so
I'm gonna have a little look I thought I
clicked on everything but maybe I didn't
so party I need something in here oh
here we go okay um it looks like a door
and I can put the door handle on on the
door right oh ok what is the door do no
idea maybe I put this on the ant hill
because you guys were saying stuff to do
with ant hill okay so this is the ant
hill but it turns into a proper anthill
wingtip hills so i'm guessing i put the
door in there now use the door with the
ant hill no that doesn't work hmm ok
well some of us move use of the meat
with the ant hill which makes no sense
but whatever no she won't try that
either a tiny house at the meet with the
house no ok this is stupid what am i
doing door with the mushrooms no but
while I supposed to do with the sound
hill it's a really big out till maybe I
can acts it down yeah it can't be done
okay thank you for the door use it on
the well okay but it's not hmm why are
you closed I made you ya know good point
okay but that's kind of progress right I
just uh I just gonna find out what else
to do now so I'm gonna cheat I got it I
got it I got it I got it I'm so stupid
so it wasn't for me to put the meat on
the ant hill outside the ant hill it was
for me to go in the ant hill and use the
meat on the man that the answer eating I
hope is correct these creepy old man
skeleton thing and if we give it some
meat something might happen maybe I can
get the bag oh yeah I tried to use it
with a bag denied there we go and
there's something here too oh don't be i
need it so we know I've got a bag and I
don't know what I need it for but is it
auntie buzz sign hmm the bag is open so
what what's in it a rat trap and some
sort of card okay what's the card you're
way exterminator okay the text is almost
gone the current number on it it says
exterminator poor Tiny Monsters
yeah okay what and then this is a rat
trap hmm alright then so can we use that
with these pinecones come on a pine
cones help me out here I'm an
exterminator see now do as I say oh oh
look away ah I'm cone I got you sorry
sir but I really need these berries so
do I have the berries now yes now the
Mamas hitting me bad mama okay so wait
do I have the berries oh no I still
trying to get the berries because the
mom is hitting me now or blue my neck
hmm thank you going it yeah I got them
and they smell delicious why do I need
the berries I think it was to put the
beetle pick to sleep so using with a
bigger pic ok so we ate them Oh pig did
you eat my cat yeah but we know this but
that make it go to sleep oh I didn't
think wait that's not even mr. midnight
I kill this bill paid for no reason hey
but we were looking for a rat you're not
my cat Oh miss you save me from misery
yeah but I need to give you some system
shrunken heads anyway so um but where is
mr. midnight assume you're feeling
disappointed who are you looking for my
cats my lovely katz mr. midnight don't
miss lady I'm very fond of cats II do
know you know your your rat you don't my
cats you don't get along a black one
with very big yellow eyes oh no the
other way a platform with very big
yellow eyes is trying to catch me oh
wait did he see wasn't fond oh I'm just
gonna shut up now Vinnie my cat is also
black wait maybe that Kara's my cat oh
my lady if he is and he's in one trouble
now he's the one in trouble why uh what
happened I can show you follow me please
it's not far from here okay
yeah i love the way walks I'm sorry
beetle pink I wish I hadn't kills you
the big topic is dead now sir thank you
now we eat ah I can't just so you know
inside the beetle peg there was no cat
but a rat a rat I'm so sorry you see my
eyes are very old i also have heart
problems that are very bad back i also
suffer from narcolepsy and sometimes it
is funny okay this let's follow this rat
is he gonna give you my door here we are
somebody took Kim miss they just
disappeared oh my goodness could you
more specific I wish I could it's it not
like the earth also they've must have
gone into the well right does anything
else I can do for you just let me know
yeah i i'm i think i need to take you to
some shrimp compares excuse me did you
steal a hair comb oh no yeah they want
the comb not the brats okay I'm not
gonna hurt you about oh the hair comb
this shiny beautiful hair comb can i
have it please all right then but can
you please cut my hair first yeah of
course i can give me where oh so happy
haha so cute thank you my lady you're
very kind yay okay sweet and then i'm
guessing that little and key oh it's a
football a little big
the little key goes to the door and then
we can get out of here okay wow these
are very early on though we need to talk
to the heads see you again have you
found that filthy but yet go find him
and bring us our home okay yeah I got
your coup it's my here no I got this
have to do with the head here's your big
taco misters oh my gosh that looks so
creepy creepy but happy oh you from the
press and you finally did it and fry the
bread hope the key opens the door you
wish to open now we fly self at last
goodbye ah they're pretty after all Oh
beautiful goodbye shiny misters have a
nice trip ok we get the key d ok let's
go let's go find some new places oh my
gosh is that the rat rat to do this to
you was it my kitty maybe ok is he
actually like that no he's still like
that that's good
let's go yeah into the well this is so
like Alice in Wonderland What a curious
little door I wonder where it will lead
me mr. midnight are you here Oh who's
that Oh creepy ok then they didn't
expect that double personality oh it's
like gonna be like two friends one even
in the pill world and one normal Oh what
she's wearing a cat hat I mr. midnight
hat oh my goodness where am i where are
you I love you little bunny it's
adorable huh what is this a hat mr.
midnight don't know your head kitty no
it's nice real head it's ok wait just a
second this isn't my kitty what's a red
hat that's good
anyways I had to buy makati hope you're
here somewhere some meat in a bowl grids
I won't lay down in that thing what's
this welcome home beautiful kitten we
hope you like your new bed be nice and
eat your food love Clara and Mia hmm
this is not home I guess he thought I
was a cat oh yeah cuz that's
understandable you can't love me they
don't even know me so I'm guessing this
is Clara and Mia holding that kitty mr.
midnight there's girls they took my
kitty no honey second spiderwick
chronicles honey bear you taste fabulous
a pint oh my don't dare to touch it
maybe you'll attack me yeah oh look a
knife Oh a sharp shiny knife a Sharpie
shining know whatever to try my little
hands I don't have soup I don't need a
spoon okay say that should be a red then
W anything else nope doop doop okay
anything in the oven for me to eat okay
could it cook my mommy told me how to
use this good good a pity of a teapot
with painted TN sir okay don't do that
it's fun to see what people have in
their homes let me see bottles and milk
are dry flowers Oh a cauldron they're
witches I'm walking this to cook a
lovely dinner for my kitty who's cool
cauldron eyes as well there's either
yeah ahead from a human I guess ok these
girls are pretty creepy I don't want to
get on the wrong side of them mm-hmm
okay see the pills this is completely
different and like the whole new room a
secret bottom with a secret inside I
want to see the secrets I'm very curious
right now obviously the secrets I can't
get it with anything helen is a baby
what are you doing here is a baby on
servers oh this is this test oh you seem
fresh yeast and alive I don't think so
with the arm out of blood oh I see you
have it comfortable there as a baby so
creepy oh wow look at this she's an
awesome climate I'd be terrified that I
was gonna fall I can't get there from
here I need a bridge okay what could I
use as a bridge hmm ok so I look up
something to wait these would be awesome
to make a bridge with no fine whatever
ok so the creepy bear was this
I have matches to like a light up the
darkness or just for fun more creepy
potion ingredients all of this but an
odd little thing it looks like a seed or
we can grow a magic Beanstalk I wonder
whose mush this is what a pretty can I
won't take somebody else's food not all
of it anyway because then you'd be like
Goldilocks squirrels body parts I don't
want to know kitty likes to play with
olives he thinks that it will insects
okay say Oh pepper always good to dress
up the soup okay why did we take pepper
that's so strange whatever
if you put this under the water nah dude
oh I know what how about we fill this up
with water I don't know why but it just
seemed logical so we did that good um
okay so how about we combine we put the
seed in the water now let's not get away
mmm where were we put some pepper in are
we gonna make your potion oh okay so I
need to boil this aha okay so i put this
on here on the stove i forgot to turn on
the fire huh okay how do I count on the
fire okay so i use the matches
it's quite wind in here the batch won't
stay lit us annoying put yeah there you
go right there you go fire okay and then
use this with that cool it's bubbling
now what do we do um come out can I put
this in here not sure if thats good and
soup I should find a recipe probably
should i'm just guessing here let's just
put this in any way ah ok fair enough
let me just quickly see if i can oh oh I
didn't even see that moonlight of
reflections oh ok i thought it's gonna
do a big Beanstalk and i could use it to
get to the bottle but still i got a blue
rose that's quite nice not too sure what
I can do with it but maybe we can put it
in the cauldron I need to find a recipe
I'm suit I'm gonna go find a recipe in a
second don't worry ok oh oh ok
oh oh look at these tweets nice deck /
sweet candy chocolate cake my favorite
should I yeah do it maybe just a little
mmm delicious and then everything looks
yummy maybe these girls aren't so bad
after all okay look at this oh did i do
the pills in the other room I don't
think I did oh we're back here again
okay fair enough strange every other
time I've taken the pills the brooms
have stayed pretty much the same i'm
always back back in that room oh hello
oh my gosh what happened in this room
hello i love our friends always just
like hey you're like half dead or your
your creepy baby but I'm just gonna say
hey to you who are you she's not gonna
can't you hear me I Fran I don't think
she cares from oh my gosh oh my goodness
to smell poor girl who kind of done this
and why I need to be careful and protect
my kitty and myself oh so creepy
haven't even taken the pills in this
room yet Oh record player what if it
works let's see
Jersey okay um oh it's hype writer and
it works i guess i could vibe but
there's no paper mmm okay there are many
books and things on the shelf I'll some
cats a bit alike really what is it is it
because of the eyes but the curious both
like to kill mice that's true and both
the good companions of witches ah i see
here they are which is obviously many
tiny paintings and there's a cat is it
going to be the same room do you think
yeah I wonder if it's gonna be the same
room upstairs as well the stairs end up
in a wall oh so they on ok the strange
let's go up these ones then
a monster who likes goats the girl looks
angry I guess he's ticklish Oh annoyed
she's so naive bless earth oh I broom to
fly away or just to clean okay the
drawer open let me see what's inside
gone they're black candles to light up
the darkness and we've got a match as
well I'll combine oh yeah fair enough
yeah this little part that is holding a
big broomstick but whatever our ladder
perhaps mr. midnight is up there this
sisters they look alike yeah the twins
Wow oh well this is a creepy room isn't
it a mirror but why is my reflection not
here hmm that is odd are you a vampire
friend hello this mirror doesn't do this
job it happened it's a pee hole maybe
it's just the deck or hmm interesting
it's a monster and so much blood I guess
I'm not the only one who can see him
then hmm these toys so ugly I hope they
didn't hear me I don't want to try I
don't want them trying to catch and kill
me Oh or tweezers tweezers to pick up
things that my little hands can't okay a
few smells like teenagers
I lie down and sit tight when I get back
home yeah I don't think you want to do
it here hello doll who called you I hope
this never happens to me I guess it
doesn't need to happen if I'm clever
enough but you keep on saying that
you're not clever enough to try things
and stuff okay this is a very strange
room oh okay so every every room in this
house has that when you take the pills
that's quite interesting oh I need to go
up the ladder
oh ok oh oh this house is so creepy
friend you're so brave you are you're
doing much better than I would have ever
done foxy oh no I wish I could take you
out of here oh wow that's nothing oh
hello little babies he's so touchy
together and that's like it has don't
cry all right she's smart be nice it's
time to sleep I don't think they are
sleeping anytime soon uh that's very
scary are you waiting for Easter jus lay
eggs or do you steal them from chick
from a chicken that's a very good
question to ask mr. midnight are you
here kitty yeah is it mr. midnight it's
a mr. midnight mr. midnight don't be
scared I'm here for you Fran is that
really you it's my cat could speak it so
cool oh dear finally um it's me come
closer please let me see you yay oh fun
i'm so happy to see you I missed you
very much I had dreams about you and
here you are thank you for not giving up
I love you my friend ah stop you're cute
I love you too is the midnight and I
really missed you our dear friend how
did you find this place after those
people took your weight Oh after those
people took you away in the woods I
tried to follow them but after a while I
got lost my senses were too weak to
track you I tried to catch some food to
recover but
something happened somebody took me and
put me in this cage oh my dear I will
open this cage we need to get to Aunt
Grace from I'm very tired I wish
everything was just a bad dream I'm
tired too but at least now we can take
care of each other van can I ask you
something sure mr. midnight what is it
did you feel my presence in your dreams
yes I did yes I did you told me to eat
the medicine and find you what medicine
Fran it wasn't really me talking to you
I think somebody was helping us get
together every time I had dreams about
you I felt the presence of something
else oh really what kind of presence for
what I felt it was human but it was
really peaceful and kind maybe it was
her parents well whatever it is it's
good and it brought us together Fran did
you hear that did you hear what oh I'll
see where this I try to find the key to
unlock you all right I love you oh I'm
sorry ah
what a pretty doll I like the hairstyle
okay creepy jellies the Toys in the
Attic always carry sadness with them
okay so do I have anything that I can
maybe give to those babies I do don't
know why those babies are there no I
keep giving my crayon now I'm sure they
wouldn't want that okay let's call them
ha ha Jesus why did I just scream at
that that's not even what the hell is
probably about to nut ah sorry what's
wrong with me okay that was yeah very
creepy I still haven't managed to find
oh hello oh you scared me I thought
nobody was living here now you are we've
been waiting for you where is your head
what my heads right here my head my head
is just in the right place you the
precious being from the other world who
would ever believe us I'm very confused
now ladies what are you talking about
Fran bow that is your name right and
your mom and dad died tragically very
brutal right and now you really want to
know who killed them right slow down how
is it that you know all of this we just
know we have to we are part of this
world okay
but don't be sad bad things happen to
all of us all the time I wish nothing
bad had happened to me I feel completely
lost don't wish for things that can't be
done find solutions and answers ah I
should do that but mummy and daddy will
never come back drink some tea and eat
some cake as always the answer tea and
cake it will make you feel better thank
you but really I need to know who told
you these things about me are you scared
little Fran a little it's not the way I
came here and this conversation makes me
feel confused you haven't asked about
your patch yet mr. midnight yeah let's
go I know that he's in your attic it's
very odd for a girl who loves her cat
tour than anything else in the world and
yet you look so calm after finding him
in a cage hungry and scared shouldn't it
be us trembling in fear of you I love
him and that's why I'm here I didn't
mean to be rude to you he wants him back
yeah of course I do yes please I really
wish to have him back he is my best
friend before we set him free tell us
about how it is you came here I don't I
came through a well that was in my
magical pill world it's a long story I
escaped from a place a very ugly place
they open the heads of children to find
out what's wrong with them Phil told me
a secret and I was clever enough to find
the way out and then I came into the
woods and mr. giant ant and then I
killed a bug and it was terrible and
then I met a rat he wanted to get his
hair down
and then i made as well and that's odd
with me here but when i entered the door
something happened i don't remember
anything else ah i saw a real pine cone
family that was before I came here they
live in mr. Antonio's house they like
berries ah and then I saw flying insect
that got stuck in trees because they
have long hair that was also in the
worse and now I'm here looking for mr.
midnight that was some adventure how are
you Fran oh why are they asking that and
I'm not sure I'm not sure anymore I
think I'm 10 years old we are 16 years
old much older than you so you have to
obey us but I am older than 16 see you
have to obey me missing uh I want to
obey you can't tell me what to do you
haven't even asked our names that's not
polite I guess yeah that's true actually
but then you already knew mine so that
was a bit creepy and you shouldn't
wander around in a house without
permission wasn't it you that brought me
in and better howl me are you stupid a
stupid little girl the family at all or
that is rude who's being rude now um
should I apologize or I am NOT stupid it
I'll apologize stop that please I'm
sorry I didn't mean to be rude are you
crying because if you are you'll get in
trouble why is that if you don't do
exactly as we say you and your cat will
die okay do you understand
no you don't scare me bring my cat now
oh no what's they doing you idiot you
asked for it if you don't do what we
asked for bad things will happen to your
cat we will force you to kill him with
your own hands oh that's that's horrible
you're evil you are evil and poisoned
but I'll do whatever you say good now
listen to us carefully we need you to
perform a little magic trick on us do
you like magic magic is magical it
doesn't like magic anyway this magic is
very powerful it's tremendous and
dangerous here is the recipe be cautious
and precise otherwise terrible things
can happen oh yeah we got the recipe y
hat UJ yourselves we can't do it it
would kill us you see we weren't like
this before we used to be two different
people in two different bodies but how
is it that you're like this now one
night a long time ago something appeared
in front of us we thought it was an
angel but it was not is it what I saw
upstairs he decided that we should spend
eternity together no it's a shadow
obviously he cares us to be like this we
never understood why we have a spell to
bring him back but we will do that later
when we are not attached to each other
anymore and show him that he is
powerless and he you will regret it
oh this sounds very scary but I guess
I'll do this for my kitty we're going
together some things you will need for
the ritual and because you have been a
very nutty girl you won't even be able
to talk to your cat you'll have to wait
until we come back yeah fine whatever
something getting back I understand I'll
be here waiting and Fran do you see this
key can you imagine what can be opened
with it or at the cage can you you silly
silly girl haha they're so mean okay
anyway i think i'm gonna leave it there
I'm so happy that we finally found mr.
midnight which is awesome and yeah I'm
quite excited to see what spell we're
going to do and if this is the spell to
detach them I'm just wondering how it's
gonna turn out this game is so creepy it
never fails to like just really creep me
out it doesn't even need jump scares or
anything although I think a good job
scared earlier on and we're just so
great gimme I come on it in the comments
below and leave me a comment in the
comments below telling me how you're
enjoying this and if you want me to
carry on playing give us a thumbs up if
you enjoyed thank you very much for
watching and have a lovely evening fine
oh it's a fetus are you okay this baby
oh it's a natural wavy it's not your
mummy how you're not there do you miss
her I miss my mommy too oh that's this
pretty revolting